that was so cool that was so awesome how
exactly does one prepare for an
interdimensional fight with a
telekinetic demon all the cast members
of stranger things had to do their own
individual prep for certain scenes and
moments let's find out who had to
undergo intense physical training mental
preparation and learning a brand new
skill we actually went on a 45 minute
walk that day do you remember number one
we think jamie campbell bower may be a
bit of a psychopath bower didn't know
anything about his character before his
audition so he decided to create his own
origin story for henry which impressed
the duffer brothers he drew inspiration
for his performance from horror classics
such as hellraiser and primal fear but
the craziest thing bauer did to prepare
was to make a board with all the faces
of the stranger things cast i went a bit
nuts for like two days he put will byers
in the center and surrounded him with
co-stars pics of the upside down and
horror icons like dracula needless to
say bower was thrilled when he got the
role there was like a sigh of relief it
was like tears
it was a big deal number two eddie was
the master of the upside down which
required joseph quinn to master master
of puppets i didn't think i'd ever be
able to kind of fulfill this kind of
quite adolescent fantasy of being a rock
star luckily quinn had a solid
foundation in guitar playing having
taken lessons when he was younger it
helped him shred out the metallica song
as he stated that most of the playing
was actually him they only had another
guitarist come in to perform the more
difficult solo besides that quinn was a
true rock star i had a bash at it number
three how many times can you listen to
your favorite song without getting sick
of it that's the question sadie sings
set out to find to prepare for her
season 4 return as max the walkman we
see in the show is real and had a real
cassette playing running up that hill
sync figured that she had to really
experience what her character was going
through she listened to the song
constantly around set and even spent an
entire day listening to it on repeat did
she get sick of it i cannot even tell
you how many times i've listened to
running up that hill it's been a lot but
i'm still not sick of it which is good
number four being held in a secret
russian prison is a great way to lose
weight david harbour can attest he lost
80 pounds from season 3 when he was 270
but weighed in for the fourth season at
190. his intense prep to lose the weight
included pilates and a whole lot of
fasting it took 8 months for him to drop
the weight but the most impressive part
he lost the weight before the show was
shut down due to kovid meaning he had to
maintain his new weight for an entire
year i don't think i'll ever do that
again
number five everybody knows the best way
to clear your head is to take a nice
long walk that's exactly what matthew
modine and millie bobby brown did the
day they had to film brenner's demise it
was a very sad day for us both the love
these two have for each other is genuine
so they decided to take a 45 minute walk
together to get into the right headspace
for the scene i honestly love millie
bobby brown number six
sometimes the mental prep is more
difficult than the physical caleb
mclaughlin had to prepare his mind for
max's goodbye because as we saw it was
very intense and emotional
i prepared for it mentally it was a long
day mclaughlin said he started preparing
for the scene two weeks prior to filming
on top of this he had to do the attic
fight scene with jason right beforehand
that is a lot to handle i think i
definitely prepared for this because
it was a sequence that i had to like
rehearse number seven when the cameras
are pointed squarely on you and all the
eyes in the room are fixated on your
person getting nervous seems like a
guarantee finn wolfhard found this out
when he had to deliver his monologue to
millie during the finale i
was like super scared about it so i like
ran it in my head over and over again
and i was i wanted to be like
as off book as i could it was a ton of
prep but it paid off they got the scene
done in a couple of takes and wolfhard
even had room to improvise the you're my
superhero yeah it was fun it was really
fun to do number eight what isn't steve
good at all the way back in the ancient
times of season 1 the brothers duff told
joe kiri that he was going to have to
film a swimming scene as part of the
school team which involved wearing a
speedo so joe wasted no time preparing
he got into great shape and took
swimming lessons to be at the peak of
his physical form it's like oh my god i
have to like get in shape and did all
these swimming lessons and you know like
i was paying for all this stuff and then
the duffer brothers decided to cut the
scenes before they even shot them
however his prep eventually paid off as
he put his skills to use during the late
scene in season 4. number 9 we honestly
don't know why this next one is
necessary the scene when charlie
heaton's jonathan and eduardo franco's
argyle or hitting golf balls into a pile
of junk required more prep than you
would think they were sent to a country
club to practice their golfing skills
and franco wasn't too happy about what
they had to wear so costume like gave us
these like very yuppy golfing golfing
outfits to go
turn up to this country club in he
instated it was very difficult to get a
handle of it although we don't think the
audience was expecting perfect technique
from two stoners hitting golf balls at
junk cars it's actually super difficult
just hitting it was so hard like there's
so much technique number 10 eddie
munsten is the quintessential metalhead
but joseph quinn not so much before the
show he didn't have any interest in
metal or d d or nerd culture but that
doesn't mean he won't convert i'm open
to anything wow quinn drew inspiration
from spinal tap to get into the
headspace of a true metalhead i think
kind of just in terms of like how uh
being a metal head isn't a part-time gig
it's you've got to take it pretty
seriously number 11 becoming henry is
one thing transforming into an
interdimensional demon is a whole other
story let's just say jaime campbell
bower got well acquainted with the
makeup chair he spent seven to eight
hours every single time they needed to
apply the vechna prosthetics which
included roughly 2425
individual pieces prep started at 3am
and once it did it was a marathon vfx
artist barry gower stated he did go into
a zen-like mode during the application
process music was a big part of this
process for bower specifically heavy
death metal just because for me it was
something that i was using as a process
to kind of um
bring up what i needed to bring up and
on the complete other end of the
spectrum he would sometimes just read a
book a perfectly balanced process this
whole thing should be number 12 riding a
skateboard is not easy i still can't
ride one sadie sink had no choice but to
learn though as her character was
required to shred some crete sync had
never even been on a board before being
cast as max so she was unsurprisingly
scared to hop on yeah it was pretty
daunting once i actually got on the
board i was like oh my god this is going
to be a lot harder than i thought it
would be but she wasn't alone finn
wolfhard a seasoned skater himself would
sometimes join her during her training
sessions which is just so freaking sweet
and these were no easy sessions it was
hard i had to like work at it for
three four months or something like that
it was every day for three hours during
that span and whenever she had a second
of free time she was ripping it
we commend the dedication the stranger
things cast has put into their roles
their preparation definitely paid off as
they delivered outstanding performances
that leave us wanting more which
preparation method did you find most
impressive let us know in the comments
and thanks for stopping by at the things